hi everyone um my name is tommy
akinemijo i'm an associate professor at
the
department of population health sciences
at duke university school of medicine
i'm very happy to be here today to
present on
my talk which is titled we don't care
what you know
until you show us that you care
characterizing access to healthcare
among black
hispanic and white cancer survivors i'm
an epidemiologist by training
and i do research that intersects
between
social and molecular determinants of
cancer health disparities
this project is mainly focused on a
social determinant of health which is
healthcare access
i have nothing to disclose
uh for today i'm hoping to start with
the background
and provide some preliminary data that
motivated this
study uh present our overview of our
study aims
and then describe how we think about
healthcare access dimensions and the
proposed measures for this study
and then present some results from our
focus groups
so according to the usci registry
ovarian cancer
was diagnosed in about 22 000 women in
2018
while it is not one of the top most
common cancers diagnosed
it does have a relatively low
five-year survival rate at about 47
percent
um we see that while incidence and
mortality has
stabilized and so much somewhat declined
slightly over the years it is still
characterized by a high
proportion of patients being diagnosed
at distance stages
so about 60 of ovarian cancer patients
are diagnosed at distant stage
where the cancer has metastasized this
translates into significantly lower
survival
at about 29 percent for distance stage
ovarian cancer
as we began our work on this topic
uh looking at the epidemiology of
ovarian cancer by race and looking at
health disparities
we were interested in looking at
progress or trends
in survival over time and again using
the cr registry
we examined five year survivor rates
among
all patients white and black ovarian
cancer patients
diagnosed compared in 1975 to 2009
we observed that there have been some
improvements in five-year survival
during that time period overall about 38
percent
improvement however when we uh stratify
this as
uh analysis by race we found that most
of this or all of this
improvement have been are restricted to
white patients who
observed about a 43 improvement in
five-year survival
in that time period while black patients
experienced a decline in five-year
survival
we were interested in looking more into
this
surprising finding and came across
literature
that have been conducted previously
showing that
for ovarian cancer the disparity appears
to be driven by
treatment completions the receipt of
guideline adherent
treatment because when survival was
stratified
was evaluated comparing black and white
patients
the main difference appeared to be
between the patients that had completed
the treatment and those that
were not so among patients that had
incomplete treatment we see
significantly lower survival regardless
of race
and among patients that has completed
treatment we see
much higher survival rates regardless of
race as well
this pattern is consistent with previous
literature showing that
as cancer becomes more amenable and
treatment becomes more effective
that is the point where we start to see
disparities emerge
and this has been described in the
context of cancer amenability
where for non-amenable cancers like
pancreatic cancers where they are not
highly effective treatments we see very
little racial disparities
but as treatment begins to improve for
example for
breast cancer and prostate cancer as
most amenable cancers
that's where we begin to see the biggest
disparity emerge
this appears to be the same pattern that
ovarian cancer
survival seems to follow
and as we began to think about access to
health care and
receive a guideline adhering treatment
you know we um
came across the insist of medicine
reports that described
how quality of care differs among
minority and non-minority individuals
and helped us think through how to
conceptualize the question
as the difference between a minority
like a black ovarian cancer patient and
a white ovarian cancer sufficient
can be understood by thinking about
differences that may be due to clinical
appropriateness
and need um differences that may be due
to the operation
of the health care system and
differences that may be due to things
like discrimination or biases
and as we think about health disparities
that's modifiable
um it's important for us to focus on the
operation of the healthcare system
or differences that may be due to
discrimination so non-clinical
associated differences
and again using this year registry we
were interested in exploring further
this concept of access to care
and how it may differ across racial
groups and how
this may contribute to differences in
receipt of quality treatment
and survival outcome so using cl we
examined the area level availability of
healthcare resources
this was defined as the proportion of
patients that had
no healthcare insurance and the number
of oncology
hospitals medical doctors and gynec
per million in the geographic region
where patients resided
we found that black patients were more
likely to live in areas that
had a higher proportion of individuals
with no health
insurance however they were more likely
to live in areas that had more oncology
hospitals
more medical doctors and more ob gyn
per million compared to white patients
however when we looked at
uh received of surgical treatment among
black and white patients we did not see
that
higher availability of healthcare
resources translates to
increased utilization of care so despite
living in areas that had more
medical resources um we found that black
patients were less
likely to receive surgery and radiation
and as a consequence of that also
experienced lower survival
so in other analysis that we did we also
found that there was no association
between healthcare resource availability
at the area level
with either stage of diagnosis surgery
or radiation among black patients
however among white patients we saw that
increasing healthcare resource
availability at the area level
was associated with reduced stage of
diagnosis
and increased likelihood of receiving
surgery radiation
and also lower mortality rates
in addition to looking at healthcare
access as availability of healthcare
resources
we also thought about other values that
might be important to cancer patients
this include things like credentials
insurance
transportation and distance and when
black and white ovarian cancer patients
were solved to ask about values that
were important to them
black patients were more likely to were
less likely to report that the doctor's
credential
was a value that was very important
compared to white patients
but black patients were more likely to
report that insurance coverage
um costs uh transportation distance
and problems scheduling visits were
factors that were important to them in
deciding who their
clinician was going to be um then we
also asked about
values in terms of are related to
beliefs and trust in their provider
and here we see really strong uh
disparities by race
where white patients were much more
likely to say
to believe that their doctors were
honest in telling them about different
treatment options
why patients were more likely to have no
worries about putting their lives
in their doctor's hands and we're also
more likely to have complete trust in
their doctors
um so this also translated to
white patients more likely to rate their
quality of their health care as
excellent compared to
black patients
in terms of outcomes we were also
interested in non-survival outcomes so
patient-reported outcomes
in the post-treatment survivorship
period
shown here for fatigue pain and
depression these are measured
using self-reports and
showing here that in addition to racial
disparities that we observed from seer
in survival there are also racial
differences in
self-reported fatigue pain and
depression and with higher prevalences
among black compared to white patients
so this all suggests to us that you know
healthcare access
um is something that is not
just related to availability of
healthcare resources
since we actually see more resources in
areas that black patients live in
but there are other aspects as well that
um blood patients indicate as being
strongly
uh important to them and um that
thinking about
the impact of lack of access to care we
need to think about not only treatment
and survival but also other self-patient
reported outcomes such as fatigue pain
and depression
so this background kind of formed the
premise for our
study where we have three aims the first
is to fully characterize
racial differences in healthcare access
dimensions
thinking about healthcare access more
broadly and more comprehensively than
in previous literature
second are looking at the association
between healthcare access dimensions and
ovarian cancer outcomes
this includes both the quality of the
initial treatment supportive care and
survival
and third quantifying racial differences
in patient reported outcomes in this
case we cannot pain depression and
fatigue
these are symptoms that are very common
among ovarian cancer patients
so as an overview we plan to do the
studies
in two phases first would involve
uh using the cr medicare database
uh to identify about 8 000 black and
white ovarian cancer patients
and characterizing only three
dimensions of access to care amongst
your medicare using
uh secondary linked data sets and then
to be able to fully capture the
subjective or patient reported aspects
of healthcare access
to do a primary recruitment study where
we recruit about a thousand
black and white ovarian cancer patients
characterize healthcare access across
all five dimensions
and then look at how those are related
to initial treatment quality
supportive care and ultimately survival
and quality of life
for our five healthcare access
dimensions we think about it as
affordability which is related to cost
and finances availability which is the
type quality and volume of healthcare
resources
accessibility which is looking at the
location of healthcare services
accommodation which is addressing
organization of
services in relation to patient's
preferences
and acceptability which is getting our
patients attitude towards
their healthcare provider
for some examples for acceptability
those include things like reputation or
credentials for the provider
interpersonal competence empathy patient
provider communication
for accessibility those are things
related to location and distance
transportation parking accommodation
um include things like scheduling
and language accessibility wait times
affordability is including things like
insurance and copays or availability is
getting at a number of
doctors hospitals and our quality of
available resources
as we have got started on this walk um
uh to identify
and characterize healthcare um access
dimensions
one of the early things that we found
out was that there was no
validated instruments that
comprehensively assessed
all five healthcare dimensions the way
we had conceptualized them
um none of the existing instruments so
that looked at
separate aspects of the dimensions were
validated for african-americans or
hispanics
and we were worried that combining
questions or sub-scales from various
surveys
into one would likely limit the internal
validity of
our instruments without doing some
initial psychometric analysis
so to address this need we apply for an
nci supplement to our grant
to fund the initial qualitative work and
psychometric analysis
to develop a healthcare access
instrument
the other thing that we discovered early
in the in the process was that there was
no study that had comprehensively
described
healthcare access barriers or challenges
among hispanic cancer patients
even though they likely have more
significant barriers to care
including things like language
immigration papers and
migration patterns within the u.s and
it's really unclear how
healthcare access barriers might
uniquely affect the quality of treatment
and patient reported outcomes for
hispanic patients
so as part of our supplement we
requested
additional funding to recruit hispanic
ovarian cancer patients in our study
so our revised study design basically
took a step back
with focus group and cognitive
interviews to
get a sense of our patient ovarian
cancer survivor's perception
of healthcare access and what the
experiences were
and then our primary cohort was revised
to include hispanic patients
and then the goal is then to
characterize the health care access
dimensions
assess social demographic epidemiology
risk factors
collect some biospecimen and then
evaluate how those influence
they received or guideline ad hearing
treatment post treatment supportive care
and survival outcomes
for the formative work for our survey
development
we realized uh
pretty quickly that would have to do
this um iteratively
so starting from a thorough review of
the literature to identify
surveys or instruments that had assessed
aspects of healthcare access
and then using that as a base um for
which we build the rest of our survey
um to inform that process and to make
sure that we
are developing an instrument that
captures the experiences of minorities
specifically african americans and
hispanics
we proposed and developed a focus group
concept elicitation
process where we recruit
ovarian cancer survivors cancer
survivors it might include breasts
breast cancer survivors as well that are
white hispanic
or african-american and asked about
their
experience with their treatment journey
for cancer
and how they perceive healthcare access
and then using that to refine our survey
and doing multiple rounds
of focus groups and cognitive testing as
we develop new
questions and then pilot test in the
final um
survey material
so uh next i will present some results
of our conceptualization
slash focus group analysis for this our
initial plan was to have
four or five groups of cancer survivors
in the triangle area come into our
office um
and you know have a very robust lively
discussion about
healthcare access and what the
experiences were
unfortunately our planning coincided
with the start of kovid and so
once everything shut down we had to
change our plans
and make change our
design to have virtual focus groups so
all of our focus groups actually
happen over zoom we think that
that may have influenced our results
because while we were
planning to do significant outreach by
going out to support group sessions and
recruiting patients from our cancer
institute um
it became um it became difficult to
to do the outreach work and so we had to
rely on
people that were already plugged into
cancer support groups
and those tended to be people that were
more of higher socioeconomic status
somewhat technologically savvy and could
figure out and navigate their way around
zoom um zoom conferencing so it's likely
that our focus groups
are represents a higher ses group than
average but we did have eight for
focus groups that are occurred over the
course of
about six weeks uh the first two groups
who are all african-american
cancer survivors residing in rural north
carolina
the next three groups are part of a
sister's network
support group which is breast and
ovarian cancer patients in raleigh and
durham
and those were also mostly
african-american survivors
we also had hispanic
cancer support group and a separate
group of nationally recruited cancer
support group
participants as well as two cancer
institution navigators
as we we recorded uh all the focus group
interactions
and uh those recordings were transcribed
for the hispanic focus group that was
actually facilitated in spanish and that
was translated before being
transcribed the transcripts were all
reviewed fully to
to become familiar with the data and
their recoding scheme
was was applied using codes that we had
initially
identified and then those who are
reviewed by the study team
we then produced cross-tabulated results
for each of the healthcare access
dimensions
and identified any new emergent codes
some of the codes um that were
defined are listed down here um and
and operationalized as uh factors that
support treatment journey and those that
negatively impact treatment
in terms of the overall um our results
of our healthcare access dimension
coding
we found that of the five healthcare
access dimensions are approved during
the focus groups
acceptability was the one that was
mentioned by all seven focus groups and
it was mentioned
um uh by far um you know
way more than each of the other
dimensions so
this this uh issues related to
acceptability came up about 41
of the time um next was our
accommodation which also
was discussed in our focus groups which
came up about 20
of the time and
um as we we assessed each
um five healthcare actions i mentioned
and asked patients
about things like what do you think
what do you what comes to mind when you
think about access to care or
if you had a choice in care what are
kind of the features
that you would be interested in or what
were the challenges that you encountered
and as indicated by the dark shades
accept
issues around acceptability showed up
regardless of how the question was asked
um again should lending support that
this was one of the top
uh factors on on cancer survivors
minds and then in terms of imagine codes
um we found that in terms of codes that
were supportive of
positive treatment experiences that
having a support system
was mentioned in all the groups and was
mentioned by far the most
at times and
in terms of codes that were challenges
that were negatively associated with
treatment
we found that our fear was the number
one
issue that patients have reported
so i will describe a few of the quotes
that came up during the
focus groups associated with each of the
healthcare access dimensions
so regarding affordability patients
experiences
included you know a participant that had
to leave work because of a diagnosis
and was fortunate to sign up for
medicaid and then had their husbands
insurance that took over
um and a separate participant whose
family went down to one income because
of the diagnosis
and because they were so sick they could
not help physically at home
making the first year of the diagnosis
being the most difficult
we also had a participant that took a
leave of absence and had insurance that
took
care of all their financial um
needs um and their copay was was
manageable
as well so we see a wide spectrum of
experiences related to affordability
regarding availability we also see a
wide
range of experiences from one
participant who said
the first question was where do i go my
um
do i go to my primary care provider or
my specialist
and not being sure what to do next just
called the hospital mainline
and was eventually connected to a
primary care group and an ob gyn group
for their treatment
um in contrast to another participant
who
already had a long-term relationship
with their primary care provider
and asked him to lead them through the
process
regarding accessibility um
an issue that came up with our rural
participants
was transportation and you know they
described having a county transportation
system
but because the boss left early in the
morning are
returned late at night regardless of the
time of treatment
that also became a challenge and another
participant who
indicated that they were hearing i i
am hearing i will be sick with nausea
and with all the appointments being told
someone has to be with you um who is
going to take me there being single
can't have people losing paychecks to
take me to an appointment
and so this was really a a challenge in
terms of being able to
go to their apartment appointments um
needing to find someone that would take
them
and stay with them throughout the whole
appointment and needing to work with
that person's schedule
in order to um to make the appointment
regarding accommodation um we heard from
several participants that talked about
um liking their surgeon skills but not
liking the wait times
taking up to an hour and a half or up to
six
hours and the wait time before studying
treatment
was mentioned as a very scary period
and someone mentioned needing to always
come in prepared because it was an
all-day appointment
regarding acceptability we there were
several quotes here and again this was
the top
um issue that participants mentioned
some of the quotes included a
relationship with my provider makes all
the treatments
and the name or reputation of the
institution is not a big factor
many black patients who do not
understand what is being told to them
there's a fear and mistrust of doctors
they don't see enough minority doctors
that they can relate to
even if doctors don't realize that
patients do an unconscious bias is a big
issue
and there was a participant that thought
there was some unconscious bias
because once they found out they were
educated they were treated better
um there are also participants that
talked about
more into went into more detail about
unconscious bias
you know they are telling doctors uh
white doctors you're biased you're
unconsciously biased when it comes to
dealing with minorities
and the discussion is made um you've got
to stop it
um so and it's unconscious and giving
seminars and courses that's helping to
improve the issue
and as a patient stepping in with the
attitude of
you're not putting me into a category
you're dealing with me justin
um as a follow-up to that another
participant um
said it doesn't matter to me as long as
you respect me
because really i think i really think
the discussion about caring
just means that you're feeling that if
someone cares about me
they are going to give me their best
work and that's the bottom line you want
the best work
and if you care about me you're going to
give me your best i think there's a
relationship between do they care
do they have good bedside manners you
relate that to getting quality care
of course that may not always be true
but that's what you're relating it to
in response to the question does the
risks of the provider matter are this
participant responded
no not at all um and like justine said
it's just how you treat me you know
respectfully
you can be a sister referring to being
an african-american doctor
and if your attitude is bad i don't have
anything for you so yes it does not
matter at all to me
as a follow-up to that even sex doesn't
matter to me
and that's participants um describe that
they are most of their team
were men um or female and they hadn't
had
a male doctor but that would not have
made a difference
it's the qualifications and how you
treat it and again
the level of compassion you have um
so i mentioned towards here that the
care is full circle it's emotional
it's physical and it's all of that put
together
um so just um again as as
i've presented with the quotes and the
data from the focus group coding
showing that you know first uh
participants understand
that healthcare access is not just one
thing
so it's not just about the finances or
the insurance
or the accessibility and being close to
a you know a highly ranked cancer
institute
but do you understand that there are
other dimensions that i play
uh things related to acceptability and
accommodation i've been able to make
appointments i've been able to
get to the hospital and the wait times
all showed up as being
important for patients however what um
really struck out was that even though
patients
understood the um kind of differences
in quality and the difference between a
cancer a comprehensive cancer center and
a community clinic
the issue of acceptability was what
often stuck with them
long term and generally overshadowed
their perception
of other aspects of their health care
and what kept showing up time and time
again was that
things related to comfort empathy
respect
and communication were the aspects that
overrode
other aspects of healthcare access for
patients
my this suggests that really paying
attention to creating psychologically
safe
environments for patients especially
when they are receiving a new diagnosis
or the beginning of treatment
should really be considered as a
cornerstone of patient-centered
high-quality care
we also found other facilitators and
barriers that
can interact with our aspects of
healthcare access
so having a strong support system seem
to be
a key factor having family members i
would go with them to appointments and
help them understand what the the
provider was saying
um faith also was a strong i was a
strong
facilitator and giving them a sense of a
sense of comfort
in going through a difficult treatment
journey
fear came up as something that would be
a barrier to
um accessing care and receiving quality
treatment
in terms of holding people back from
wanting to
engage with providers or wanting to go
in out of fear of getting the bad news
um and also mental and emotional
awareness you know just um being psycho
psychologically ready to go through this
the other factor that came up several
times was a role conflict
where for participants that were used to
taking care of people
and were usually the um
the main source of support for their
family now needing help themselves and
needing to
accept that role as seemed also to be a
barrier to care
so in summary um it appears that you
know healthcare access is definitely a
complex
um construct it has multiple dimensions
um each one of the dimensions are
important however
um in terms of the patient provider
interaction this seems to have
the most impact on patients
satisfaction with their care and just
their psychological safety
during the course of their cancer
treatment
in terms of creating patient centered
high quality care
this is actually one um dimension of
healthcare access that might be easier
to intervene on
by providing training for providers and
not just the oncologist but the entire
healthcare team
to be able to provide this empathetic
respectful
healthcare system for patients
so with that i would just like to
acknowledge
the co-investigators and trainees and
staff that have contributed to this work
and also to acknowledge funding by the
national cancer institute
thank you